[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
it's four million subs Eve
it was a it was a cold and dark
September second always well on 4
million subs Eve here's you guys all 4
million of you all 4 million 4 million
subs Eve
the story of the core of digital
air-conditioner started in 2011 in loft
in Los Angeles California where it was
myself Sam and Nico and we were working
there was 95 degrees we said you know
what we don't have the money right now
we'd rather just go and deal with it and
now five years later we finally decided
to bite the bullet and pay for the air
conditioning and I got to tell you we
were just out shooting today it was
super hot and we get back and it's nice
and cool in here it is worth every penny
we learned a couple things from stress
level zero in the process of getting
this air conditioning because the guy
that we had over there well I don't got
to tell you guys thank you there is a
pipe in the tool room that's leaking
water all over the shelves in our tool
room
how many AC units do you have to install
we're two out of the three leak water to
be dumping water somewhere now what do
we do now we found a new guys name just
Waldo Oswaldo marisco hooked it up he
did a great job he actually took the
time and detail to do things properly on
the roof even though you can't see that
that thing is pumping out sweet sweet
cool air and our pumps not leaking
because he took the time to get a bigger
one and to put it in the wall and it
doesn't look too damn bad either
the future now is bright at corridor
digital it is so bright I know these are
first world problems okay even without
air conditioning we still got it made in
the shade but the point is it's been a
long journey and we've worked for it and
we work for it and we worked for it
there are three things that I will
remember in my lifetime when I'm on my
deathbed number one the day that my kids
going to be born
number two the day that I got married
and number three the day we got air
conditioning in corridor digital day
many and the day I met Renton